each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
grafton thank you for coming I'm glad to
have Martin ester he's a associate
professor in the Department of computing
sciences at Simon Fraser University in
Vancouver he's also the director of
databases and data mining group and
today is going to talk about his work on
joint cluster analysis using both
attributes and relational data and this
if I remember right this is work from
the Scion data mining conference last
year where it was one of the best papers
presented so we're glad to have him here
this afternoon thank you very much Aaron
welcome to my talk everybody thank you
for the invitation I appreciate the
opportunity of introducing you to some
of our current research and trying to
explore some common interests the talk
is about joint class analysis of
attribute data and relationship data
problems algorithms and applications I'm
trying to present a mix of something
reticle and some more practical results
so if you are more than vertically
minded please hang out if you are more
practical minded please hang out you
will hopefully both find some good
nuggets in the store please feel free to
interrupt me whenever you want to
whenever you have any any questions or
comments throughout the talk I want to
keep this as interactive as possible
so cluster analysis is one of the
primary data mining tasks that has
received a lot of attention in various
communities for decades already the
purpose of clustering is to find groups
the so-called clusters of object with
internal cohesion and external
separation it means we want to group
objects together into clusters that are
is this as similar as possible to each
other and as dissimilar as possible from
object or entities of other clusters the
slides presents two toy the two
dimensional data sets with more or less
significant cluster structure in
immediately tells us that there are more
obvious and less obvious more difficult
cluster structures hidden in a data set
if you look at the data mining and
machine learning literature the majority
of clustering algorithms would be
attribute based normally they use the
ant abused to determine certain pairwise
the distance function which is then the
main ingredient of a clustering
algorithm partitioning clustering
algorithms such as K means I'm actually
could clustering algorithms such as
single link density based clustering
algorithm assumptions DB scans would all
be representatives of this a category of
clustering algorithms there another
major class of clustering algorithms is
graph based or clustering algorithms
which assume a graph-based the data
representation and will then lead to
some kind of minimum cut graph a
partitioning problem in order to
partition the graph into sub components
which would correspond to hopefully
meaningful clusters now it's worth her
to point out that there are very few
classic
then consider both types of data
attribute based clustering algorithms
would normally focus exclusively on the
attribute side of things where r are
based clustering algorithms are normally
focusing more or less exclusively on the
discreet relationship data however in
many practical applications objects to
have both aspects antabuse and
relationships attribute data describing
the intrinsic or internal
characteristics of object relationship
data describing the extrinsic external
influences and relationships among
object market segmentation will be one
of our running examples can be
considered as an example of a broader
class of community identification
problems where we would have objects
naming customers described by
demographics age gender income and so
forth classical attribute data as well
as social relations which naturally
would be represented as a relationship
or graph data but many other
applications have similar properties if
you look at documents documents would be
represented by both the term frequencies
and call all the relationships genes can
be represented by the gene expression
profiles measuring the degree of
expression of genes in certain
conditions or experiments as well as the
relationship between the corresponding
proteins as represented by some
protein-protein interaction network
crimes we mentioned this on many other
crimes can be represented by a crime
frequencies as well as certain
relationships among crime locations as
represented by some underlying road
network images quite different
application in images the objects would
be pixel that
could be described by certain color
values as well as enabled relationship
the spatial neighborhood relationship
among pixels now why should we consider
both attribute data and relationship
data in clustering obviously if
attribute data and relationship data are
more or less redundant and in the
extreme case can even be derived from
each other then there would be no point
of using both the internal taneously and
of course there are such applications we
are not trying to argue that in every
case this is meaningful that certain
these cases we attribute data and
relationship data and relatively
redundant however there are also many
cases as we argue the anti-v data and
relationship data are complementary and
do indeed provide additional information
compared to using only a single data
type now at the abstract level the
purpose of using both data types is to
help resolve ambiguities in the
clustering obtained when using only one
of the data types now let me use this
abstract example here to illustrate this
point further let's assume we have these
eight object described by the attribute
to dimension attribute values only now
when trying to find k equal to two
clusters you rent a object in the middle
seems to be critical the assignment to
one of the two clusters is ambiguous now
when taking into account the graph or
relationship data and learning this kind
of relationships among these objects it
immediately becomes clear that this
critical object should be assigned to
the left cluster because it's much more
closely connected to this cluster than
to the right cluster there are also
situations where the opposite holds
assuming that we have data as a small
data set and represented by the
relationship data only now the
assignment of the
critical objects in the middle would
again be a less than obvious now by
adding the attribute data as a second
layer a second perspective we can easily
resolve this ambiguity and assign this
red object to the right cluster because
it significantly closer in terms of
attribute values to this cluster now
coming back to our concrete application
of market segmentation in market
segmentation we have customers with
demographics data as we have seen
already customers with close
demographics are much more likely to
respond similar to a certain product
offer or campaign so attribute data is
certainly important for market
segmentation however people are
skeptical and trust my friends more than
any companies or anonymous offers so it
has been increasingly recognized in the
literature and I guess in industry as
well that relationship data social
networks need to be taken into account
for market segmentation of a marketing
as well so it market segmentation seems
to be driving application which
motivates joined cluster analysis of
attribute and relationship data now let
me briefly outline the rest of the stalk
I will briefly discuss some related work
and please feel free in particular to
interrupt me then ask questions
obviously I need to be kind of selective
in the choice and discussion of related
work I would be glad to discuss any
further related work that you may want
to discuss afterwards I will introduce
our former problem definition in this
framework of John class analysis
introducing the connected pay center
problem as we call it we will discuss
algorithms will
start with approximation algorithms and
then move on to more practical heuristic
algorithms will discuss applications
including some more or less preliminary
experimental evaluation on real-life
data before concluding the salt and as I
mentioned this talk is based on our SDM
assigned data mining conference paper
last spring as well as on some follow-up
work that we have recently submitted to
Jonah multi relation clustering is
probably the first area that comes to
your mind when thinking of joint cluster
analysis and related work in general in
motivation the data mining we deal with
multiple tables rather than individual
single tables as used in propositional
classical data mining methods now when
classing one of the tables in my
tradition cluster we would consider not
only the single table and its antabuse
well also relationships to other tables
as well as etiquette of these related
tables no there has been some work on
motivation clustering in my opinion the
probabilistic relational models based
approach is the is certainly seminal
work in this area of modulation
clustering there are others as well this
was worked by tasca at all back in 2001
the probabilistic relational models were
introduced as a first order
generalization of the well-known
Bayesian networks then consists of two
components different from a Bayesian
network that consists of a single graph
structured Network only they consist of
the Eurasian ille skeleton as recorded
which corresponds to the database schema
as well as the relationships between
variables representing attributes of the
participating tables and secondly the
so-called a neural network which
corresponds
closer to the database instance to the
set of tuples from different tables now
when using a PRM for clustering we would
have to add unobserved variables one
variable for each of the participating
tables representing the unobserved
unknown a priori unknown cluster
membership now this slide presents a
simple example of a probabilistic
relational model from a medical domain
so we have to a solidly table t1 table
for patients another one for strains of
infectious bacteria or viruses as well
as the third table for contact persons
the arrows represent director
dependencies between variables of the
same or different tables the dotted
areas represent the foreign key
relationships between tables that are
expressed and unknown from the
relational database schema so and this
is actually this p.m. here is not using
any unobserved variables so this is a
sim the basic p.m. that is normally used
for classification rather than casting
purposes just to briefly dive into one
of these variables here to clarify the
meaning a little bit this is a variable
transmitted for example according to
this network here depends directly on
the close contact variable or attribute
of the same table the contact person of
reference it also depends venky on the
HIV result of patients of all patients
that have interacted with this
particular contact person you know and
then basically for each node would have
a conditional probability table very
similar in style to the basin networks
the other area that I briefly want to
mention as related work is senior
supervisor clustering and based on the
observation that cluster labels are
sometimes known in advance for some of
the objects obviously not for all of the
objects but for some of the objects now
this observation motivated the
introduction of constraints on pairs of
objects muscling constraints that
expense a constraint then two linked
objects must belong to the same cluster
cannot link constraints expected special
situation that the two linked objects
should not belong to the same cluster
now it turns out that these constraints
are not necessarily simultaneously
satisfiable in a certain context which
implies that normally these constraints
are considered as soft rather than hard
constraints now this leads us to the
problem of semi-supervised casting which
aims at discovering a good clustering
with respect to attribute values in the
classical non supervised setting that
certain that on top of this classical
objective function respect the given
muscling and cannot link constraints as
good as possible now again this topic
has received a lot of attention I'm
selecting just one of the best papers in
my opinion here to briefly introduce
some more concept buzzell at i'll have
proposed the probabilistic framework
back in 2004 which is based on hidden
markov random fields where the observed
variables represent attribute values or
data points the hidden variables
represent again the cluster labels edges
or neighborhoods represent the both must
and cannot links now so we have the
observed data here on the upper level
the hidden class labels as well as the
links on the lower level in this case we
want to find k equal to three clusters
so based on the mast links we know that
the X for X 1 and X 3 must belong to the
same cluster say cluster 1 we know that
x 6 cannot be linked with either of
these objects so this would fall into
separate the second cluster now x 6 is 0
x.x I've and x 2 are not participating
any constraint so we have all the
freedom to assign them to either of
these the dresser that we want to find
now remember that we also want to
minimize the clustering cost we want to
maximize the compactness of the
corresponding clusters so consequently X
2 would be assigned to this first
cluster because it close to its centroid
whereas x5 would be too far away from
the centroid it would be more effective
from the point of view of maximizing the
objective function to include it into
the new cluster the third cluster so we
have already mentioned and constrained
in clustering hours these pairwise must
link and cannot link concerns are very
specific kind of cluster ring conferring
there's more general cluster constraints
available in many applications and this
has led to another field called
constraint crashing both in data mining
and machine learning researchers have
developed different formalisms and
corresponding algorithms to express
constraints such as cluster cardinality
constraints constraints on the average
values of clusters and so forth so basic
different from the semi-supervised
passing these are all cluster level
constraints near semi-supervised
constraints are all the instance level
concern so
relating pairs of instances now these
constraints are typically cluster of
class level contains constraining a
certain set of objects group together in
a cluster now many of these constraints
can be formulated in SQL this has been
used as one of the languages to explain
such constraints tongue at all have
suggested one of the first constraint
clustering algorithms in a 2000
constraint partitioning clustering
algorithm let's briefly illustrate this
for this case of two-dimensional points
assuming we want to find k equal to 2
clusters and we restrict the cardinality
to be at least four now obviously the
three guys on the right side would
violate this cluster cardinality
constraint so we would have to include
the closest among the object on the left
hand side from the natural class on the
left hand side to form a first cluster
satisfying the cardinality constrained
the remaining object would be included
in the second cluster in order to
maximize the value of the objective
functional minimizing the average
distance between a point and the
corresponding cluster Center you know
are there any questions concerning
related work or any comments
okay then I'll move on then let's come
on to our problem definition for joint
cluster analysis so the first question
that we need to address here is if you
want to combine attribute and
relationship data how do we want to
combine these two data types into a
single coherent problem definition and
as we have seen in our discussion of
related work they're essentially two
alternatives we can either perform a
multi-objective optimization
simultaneously optimizing an objective
function on both of these data types or
alternatively we can formulate the
problem is somewhat estimating manner
using one of the data types for
constraining the solutions using the
other data type for defining some
objective function that would be
optimized and we have investigated the
second approach now considering the
characteristics of the two data types
namely that anti hbu data is inherently
continuous or normally continuous not
always reiationship data is discrete we
are using the relationship data to
define constraints and using the
antibiotic to define an objective
function that would be optimized now
similar to semi-supervised casting and
to constrain clustering and different
from alteration in clustering we are
dealing with the case of a single table
oh nice oh this is not multi relational
data mining now given a data set capping
the D as a so-called informaiton graph
graph where nodes are associated with
attributes or attribute vectors with an
outside capital V international capital
e okay the number of intended clusters
to be discovered connectivity constraint
that clusters need to be connected graph
components this is the connectivity
concern that we formulate on the
relationship data the classical
objective function
from many partitioning clustering
algorithms name me that yeah actually so
I need to be careful this is not the
objective function that we are using in
the connected AK Center problem is
measures the maximum distance between
cluster nodes and plus the center so
basically we take the rages of clusters
as your objective function you may
wonder why you're using this we are
using this because this makes it
possible to analyze the complexity and
makes it possible to develop
approximation algorithms as we'll see
later the resulting practical heuristic
algorithm can easily be applied to the
corresponding k-means version of our
problem where we use the eunice average
distance between the point and the
corresponding cluster Center as the
objective function so taking these
ingredients the task of the connected k
Center problem is as follows find the K
centers K nodes from our information
grave and the corresponding partitioning
of the into K clusters such at first
each cluster is internally connected
meaning every pair of nodes in the
cluster is connected via an path of
objects from within this cluster
secondly the objective function is
maximized sorry minimize of God's of
Ages is minimized center has you want
the notes yes
or are you using some yummy variables
that represent the center that's what I
don't get that clearly so that the
dissenters have to be one of the nodes
they have to the class the center's have
to be the center's have to be a notes
object of our database hypothesize
cluster you find the note that minimizes
radius yes so we find k centers K nodes
and the assignment unique assignment of
the remaining nodes to one of these k
centers such that the each of the K
clusters is internally connected and
minimizes the overall cluster radius
so can you talk a little bit more about
the logic behind speaking the notes
themselves vendors is that a little bit
restrictive rather than that using
Rachel points like means yet because i
can think of stage they use we're having
the notes themselves or centers may not
work at all yeah let me say media if we
forget the joint class analysis for a
second if we go back to simple classic
partitioning clustering algorithms we
have two main paradigms here we have the
k-means like clustering algorithms and
the came a to eat the night clustering
algorithm right so even in classical
partitioning clustering algorithms we
also have this I mean it this is well
accepted a paradigm of representing
clusters either by a cluster element or
by a cluster by virtual poor the gravity
center of the class right Mindy
obviously missing you have the k-means
problem is in a very easier than the K
meadow a problem or the other hand they
came into it problem is more general
because it doesn't require points and to
be represented in the euclidean vector
space right so it's more applicable
because it just requires a pairwise
distance action so it's I mean this
certain in it certainly has and let me
see me maybe we move on to the next hour
we motivate this problem once more now a
running example of market segmentation
right it's so the to illustrate the
meaningfulness of the problem definition
and certainly it's when that there are
some limitations when you require a
cluster centers to be
the data objects however we feel that
many application this is acceptable now
take a market segmentation again now our
cluster model this K connected case in
the problem corresponds to an approach
where we design a specific product offer
or campaign or product bundle for
certain customer group work a certain
market segment you send the offer to the
cluster representatives to the
representatives of each of the K cluster
so in this case you would certainly want
to send it to a real person and then let
the customers propagate the offer within
their segment if they like it now the
center nodes serve as cluster
representatives the connectivity
constrained in this case allows us to
model the word of mouth phenomenon the
objective function seems to make sense
because the smaller the ranges the
smaller the distance between cluster
elements and their corresponding
representative the similar more similar
their demographic data the product the
purchase preferences the more likely
that cluster elements will like the
offer and propagated further from the
central no totally yeah the average path
links with maximum path length also
within a cluster we'll also talk about
how easily things will propagate yes do
you look at that at all oh the at you
mean the average path things yeah
leverage maximum reach either yeah
missing yeah let me say in this this is
the easier ethical problem definition
this problem definition we just
considered the Rangers we also we can
briefly mention this data we can easily
replace the objective function by an
objective function that minimizes the
average distance between cross the
elements and the corresponding center
there's also you can also obviously we
can come up with a stricter connectivity
constraints and we'll talk
this a little bit later actually quite
at the end of the talk in our future
work so this was so missing this was the
first step into this direction of joint
class analysis so we had a relatively
theoretical approach but as we'll see we
also have some practical algorithms and
we have some experimental results now
but let's discuss the theoretical
aspects first how hard is the problem
does it make sense to find the correct
complete and exact solutions to this
problem and it turns out that the
connected k Center problem is very hard
it is np-complete for k equal to two
clusters even for the simplest case of
the equal to one dimension so it's even
harder than the classical k center
problem and related problems the proof
uses the reduction from the three CNF
s80 problem and i just briefly want to
sketch the the idea of this proof the
CCF s80 problem is defined as follows
given a set of variables capture you
with n variables you want to you and a
boolean formula C which is the
conjunction of M sub formulas c 12 CM
where each of these see I is the
disjunction of exactly three literals
and each of the literals is either
variable or negated variable from our
alphabet chapter you decide whether they
exist the truth assignment of capital u
that makes C hold in order to prove the
NP completeness in order to reduce the
CKC problem from the s80 problem we need
to consider the decision version of the
connected Kane Center problem where
instead of optimizing the
radios we asked whether for certain
wages are there are K centers such as
all nodes can be assigned in a connected
manner within radius R to one of the K
cluster centers so this is the decision
version equivalent version of the
connected k center problem now let's
briefly illustrate the idea of the
reduction we assume k equal to 2 and D
equal to 1 the simplest case the proof
can easily be generalized to other cases
now obviously the task is to model the 3
C and F s80 problem as it connected can
Center a clustering problem now how do
we do this we introduce nodes for the
sub formula C 12 CM 1 node each we
introduce nodes for the variables and
the negated variables you want to you n
we introduce two nodes that will be
serving as cluster centers want to find
k equal to two clusters now we have
these technical gadget here at the top a
1 2 a n and b1 to BN which will make
sure that you I and you I bar must be in
different clusters right this is a
constraint that is inherent in the
logical SED problem right a variable is
either either the variable oh its
negation is too now let's look at the
attribute side of things we basically
order the nodes on this one-dimensional
axis here so in this basic this axis
represents the single attribute values
of all B's obtain the value of 0p0
become gets a value of r the given
Raiders are the variables you I enter
not you I get a very
to rp1 ends up with the value of the r
and the remaining well the reigning
notes ai and see i get a value of four
are now if you want to find two clusters
satisfying this radius constraint we
have no choice then and to use p0 and p1
as the two cluster centers to assign the
B aizawl to p0 the ai's and c is to p1
and for the new eyes and not you guys we
have the choice to assign them to either
of the two cluster centers right and
using these technical gadgety and the
corresponding edges in our chosen graph
we can make sure that each of the UI's
must be in different classes now the
interpretation of these processes as
follows the cluster of p0 will serve as
our ports clusters so this will contain
all variables that evaluate to Ford's
where's the cluster p1 centered at a p 1
corresponds to the true cluster
containing all variables you I that
avira lead to 2 in our formula now in
order to make the in order to basically
see I as it must be connect me part of
this p 1 cluster so consequently every
CI must be connected to p1 via at least
one of its literals right so every CI is
related to ever oh I forgot to mention
this every CI is related to the three
literals that occur in the sub formula
now in order to enforce this constraint
everything I must be connected to p1 by
at least one of its leaders which is
exactly equivalent to the formulation of
the 30 requirement of the CCF s80
problem may be that in order to evaluate
the entire former 22 each of the year
sub formulas must have at least one
valid little
so this is the idea behind the reduction
of these connected k Center problem from
the three CNF s80 problem now this was
the abstract proof there's also some way
of intuitively illustrating the hardness
of the problem given K centers and the
Raiders are even in this situation when
we have already a certain k and centers
and a given radius finding the optimal
assignment for the remaining nodes is
already NP hard this can be seen easily
from the following example the reason is
that there are some critical nodes that
we call articulation node notes that are
within Raiders are from more than one
cluster Center and from which other
nodes depend in the assignment so for
example in this case here the assignment
of note B depends on the assignment of
articulation node a as soon as we assign
a to cluster 1b need to be signs of the
same cluster if you sign a to the second
cluster B would have been assigned to
the second cluster as well so the
assignment of different note is not
independent which is different from the
classical k-means okay Center problem
where as soon as we found case centers
the assignment of the main point is
straightforward because it's independent
from each other so this is intuitively
the reason why the connected k Center
problem is so hard now given that the
problem is np-complete there's no hope
of coming up with an efficient algorithm
that finds an exact solution and to the
problem however as we will see it is
possible to construct an approximation
algorithm that finds the solution with
certain quality guarantee the solution
that is not more than three times as
expensive as the optimal solution this
algorithm it works in a polynomial and
runtime it makes use of a relaxed
version of the cacique see problem that
we call ck c prime problem it's very
similar to the KC KC problem exam then
it allows clusters to overlap this is in
relaxation now we will show how to solve
the CKC prime problem in polynomial
runtime we consider every possible
radios are and the possible rey de are
those pairwise distances of nodes we
consider them in increasing order now
for a given are we try every combination
of care centers okay of the N elements
of our data set okay of the n nodes of
our informative graph we perform a
breadth-first search the actual Raiders
of our starting from each of the que el
County and consider the cluster centers
now this breadth first search this
limited Baxter search allows us to
determine whether the problem the CKC
Brian problem is solvable for the given
K cluster centers and the chosen are
right as soon as we find the solution we
terminate so this algorithm finds us the
exact solution to the CKC prime problem
in polynomial run time in the runtime of
the order of n to the power of k plus 2
times log N and the main cost factor
here is the enumeration of these K or
combinations of K cluster centers now
the second ingredient that we need for
our vaccination algorithm is the
conversion of a solution given exact
solution to the CKC prime Robin called C
1 prime to seek apron with respect to
ranges are into a solution c 1 to c k of
the original CKC problem
respectively are so we lose right not
surprisingly we lose some accuracy with
this conversion this conversion keeps
the same cluster Center so we don't
touch the cluster centers that were
found for the CKC prime and problem but
obviously we need to assign nodes
uniquely to one of the classes this is
main challenge now the algorithm works
as follows and we iterate over the K
clusters see i from 1 to K we first deal
with the nodes of CI prime event we
basically built cluster CI we first
consider the nodes of CI prime that have
not yet been assigned to another cluster
we want to keep them as far as possible
in the same cluster again we perform
breadth first search up to Raiders of
our now comes the difficult part now we
need to deal with the note that are
reachable only via some articulation
node so we deal with the nodes that were
part of si I prime in the relaxed
problem then we are reachable via an
attic from CR they are reachable from
see I the center of CR I'm via an
articulation node that has now in the
unique or part in the partitioning has
now been assigned to cluster CJ j
smaller than I so this articulation is
gone already into another cluster right
and now this node happens to be
unconnected to the center of CI in the
partitioned solution of the data set so
sorry i forgot means so that this is a
problem what do we do with this point
being inside this point now two of the
only thing that we can do is we sign
this point to the point which its
corresponding articulation node has been
assigned previously already now the
question is how much accuracy do we lose
now let's illustrate this situation with
this slide here let's assume that
the yellow note a VP prime is this
articulation note shared by C 1 Prime
and C 2 prime now this red node BP is a
note that depends on the assignment of
this articulation knowed it was a part
of C 2 prime it was within radius R from
c2 it's no longer connected to see to
because we assigned the CVP prime to c 1
the earlier class of c1 right now how
much can we lose and let's briefly
analyze this we know that the distance
between VP Prime and C 1 is bounded by
our because this node is part of both C
1 and C 1 prime now the distance between
VP Prime and V P Prime this is basically
the loss when assigning a VP prime to
see one rather than to see to write this
distance is a due to the triangle
inequality it cannot be larger than the
sum of the distances between VP Prime
and V P and V peopre distance between V
T Prime and C 2 now the we know that
both of these distances must be bound by
our why because this VP prime was part
of C 2 prime and it is also right so
when both of these distances are bound
by our so consequently the distance
between VP and VP prime is smaller or
equal to 2 are now taking these two
terms together and applying the triangle
inequality again we can prove that the
distance between VP Prime and C 1 the
new cluster Center to which we assign it
in the unique
solution cannot exceed we are so now
taking together this exact solution this
exact algorithm for the CKC prime
problem and this conversion algorithm
which is the three approximation are
going to be obtained as the
approximation algorithm for our or
internal CKC problem ok so this
approximation algorithm is theoretically
satisfying it delivers this desirable
performance guarantee its polynomial
runtime unfortunately as we have seen
the polynomial runtime is relatively
high it the runtime is higher than n to
the power of K already because of the
expensive enumeration of all
combinations of K cluster centers
consequently we have developed a
heuristic algorithm that came as well to
launch a databases we call this
algorithm Net scan the overall
algorithmic scheme is very similar to
many optimization algorithms such as
k-means so in the first step we
initialize k cluster centers somehow we
will see this in a second we assign the
many nodes to one of the cake on the
cluster centers we recalculate centers
and we continue until convergence now
and we mentioned this already i want to
point this out here once more the same
eigen next can can be used to solve not
only decay a connected k center problem
but also the connected k-means problem
basically pc we needed they can connect
the case enter problem mainly for the
sake of being able to analyze the
quality and to come up with an
approximation I will as soon as we don't
need the approximation guarantee anymore
we can easily replace the center's by
the means okay so the main challenge as
we've seen already of the heuristic
algorithm is the assignment of the main
notes2 k current cluster centers
everything else is straightforward and
in principle you would like to grow the
K clusters in parallel assigning points
or nodes to one of the K cluster centers
as soon as they become connected with
respect to the current radios are now is
a sequential simulation we incrementally
increase the Raiders are starting with
small initial radius R 0 each rating for
current wages are I iterating over the
cake aster centers assigning all nodes
to see I that are reachable from CI with
a better search within distance I if not
all of the nodes have been assigned
within the current maximum Raiders are I
we increase our I and resume from steps
to answer all nodes become assigned to
one of the clusters we also perform some
limited look ahead to treat the
articulation nodes that we have
mentioned already now this slide
illustrates the idea of the Nets can I
goes much more so in this case want to
find two clusters and we have 2 chron
cluster Center c1 and c2 now we start
with the initial radius R 0 no node is
connected to see one within this radius
1 node at the bottom is connected to c 2
for these radios so there's still some
on the site nodes we continue trying the
larger next larger radius r1 now within
our one U and V become connected to OC
one however now V is one of these
critical articulation nodes assigning
v2c Prime Steve answering would imply
that W would also have to be assigned to
c 1 and w would not be reachable within
Rangers are 1 so consequently we need to
continue we try the same rages for c2
the same problem applies you would be
the complicated outlier in this point of
view so we need
continue within our one UV can neither
be assigned to classes c1 to c2 so we
try the next larger radius increment are
to within which all nodes are connected
and reachable from cluster Center c1 and
we are done for this small point example
let's discuss some more algorithmic I
challenges here it's well known that the
initialization of all these optimization
algorithms is a crucial and we propose a
random initialization of cluster centers
with a certain modifications we wait the
probabilities of drawing a particular
node as a cluster Center with its degree
based on the intuition that higher
degree cluster centers have a higher
probability of generating a larger
connected component it's certainly it's
only a heuristic the radius increments
another important ingredient of the
method and there's a trade-off as
follows the more increments we consider
the more accurate becomes our solution
the smaller the radius of the solution
that we discover of course on the other
hand we increase possibly unnecessarily
increase the run time of the algorithm
so we have proposed compromise to set
the radius values and in particular the
radius increment the treatment of
articulation notes is is one of the main
challenges of the method and again we
are proposing compromise here the as we
know from the theoretical analysis we
cannot expect to efficiently consider
all solutions and find the optimal
solution so what we do is as compromise
we consider only the unary name
neighbours the degree one neighbors of
articulation nodes these neighbors are
on one hand extremely critical because
there's only one way of connecting them
to one of the UK you can cluster centers
and secondly these unary nodes can be
efficiently a dealt with so this is our
compromise near istic that we pursue in
the nets game algorithm for treating the
articulation of the runtime of the
netscreen algorithm is order of I times
K times capital e times diam / kappa de
i where i denote the number of
iterations which cannot be analyzed
theoretically diane the maximum pairwise
distance and kept the ID a chosen
greatest increment so this algorithm is
promises to be efficient in scale well
to large databases now let's move on to
the last chapter applications for joint
custody at is's so this will be partly
report on experimental evaluation that
we have performed already party we are
sketching potential applications of the
joint class analysis paradigm that we
have started to investigated over the
last little while so the driving
motivation yeah that one previous like
to slide before really constraints
kidding this one yeah the constraint is
the internal connectivity constraint
every cluster must be internally
connected meaning every pair of nodes in
the cluster must have one part
connecting part consisting exclusively
of cluster nodes between yes and the
cluster Center and where you get the
edges from
represent all the edges are input we we
assume that the data is given as an
infinitive graph where we have both
edges of basic notes are associated with
attribute information and I mean edges
are assumed to be given from the data
set its mean we use the marketing
communication as our driving application
in market segments the edges would be
social relations for example and the
attribute data would represent
demographic are they done for example in
market segmentation are you assuming
that the follicle n nodes you'll know
all the ratios for like all the N
squared relations on activities for the
case CKC problem we are assuming that we
know the graph structure that's a very
good question it's it's a and it
basically it motivates me say less
strength connectivity constraints right
in this region problem definition we
request that every cluster is connected
right so now if there's in deeds are
missing edges then basically we would
not be able to find the solution to the
KC KC a problem right now we can do one
way of generalizing this is making the
problem probabilistic right allowing
basic like smoothing basic smoothing the
probabilities right allowing to insert
edges with a certain no probability even
if they have not yet been observed right
but this is once more I mean this was
the first
step into this direction or joint cast
analysis in this in the original problem
definition we seem assume complete
knowledge of the graph of the
relationship data as well as the
interval data this is between the
attributes yes wait is this respect to
the Antikythera so once more in market
segmentation the radius would represent
the similarity in demographics or
purchase preferences between cluster
customers that are grouped together into
one cluster and the relationship would
represent the social network the other
question have is articulation nodes they
seem to be the crucial constraint
generators how do you I'm going to tell
you care about how you select them
because it seems like a group select
many choices of articulation noise would
be two different types of customers yeah
yeah I mean we we determine them on the
fly as soon we iteratively increase the
arrangers right we blow up the maximum
radius that we consider in a certain
interation right as soon as we realize
that the point is reachable we meet and
we perform this breadth first search
right from me in principle we get to be
you take one step look ahead you know
that you end up you can only be reached
from V and there probably is not a
collision or generated decision we know
we know that we perform breadth-first
search starting from the K cluster
centers right we increase the wages that
we can go away from the cluster centers
so we know that V is reachable from both
c1 and c2 we also know that it is within
radius R from both of the cluster
centers right as soon as we detect this
we look ahead right and we could look
ahead in principle you could look ahead
as much as we want to write obviously
the price at the price of increased run
time right so what we do in our current
algorithm is we just consider you know
in a
as of these articulation nodes consider
their attribute values their distance
from the participating cluster centers
and use this as our input for the
cluster assignment of this article a
shin of me for example let's see the
connection between us little shorter was
the same lenders VAW yes so for the
third circle the third radius yes the
UVW three nodes can belong to either c1
or c2 if you was positioned for example
here that's right yeah so if you use
position there yes for the largest
circle the largest radius it would
belong to vote the cluster C 1 and C yes
and then you would have some kind of you
have to resolve the conflict at that
point yes you mean that's easy because I
mean in principle if you would like to
grow the cluster simultaneously we can't
write in hours in a sequential algorithm
we try the clusters one at a time right
we we perform better search up to radius
R I for cluster C 1 if you can connect
it to this cluster and have no
articulation all right then we assign it
right so basically we consider the
clusters in increasing number of the
index that's the way to resolve these
ambiguities between different competing
clusters within one iteration additional
nodes Issei attached to our the uo w yes
the olden you want step look at you
essentially assign me take the penalty
yes and we are certainly aware of the
fact that there's some room for
improvement definitely and we mean we
have investigated some alternatives and
but as we have seen some theoretical
analysis this is here d a hard problem
right we can even but I don't we can I
could complicate the situation it will
be further but I want to refrain from
doing
yeah yes so why not eh only represent
the relationship I yes sorry to know yes
so I'm singing myself a way to combine
the relation and the distance of the
educate distance in Google menu and let
the edge disturb you does not value yes
this this is this can be done and this
has been done that and it's it's it's a
feasible approach but of course me you
lose one thing you lose the origin of
this information right I mean it's one
of the one of the strings of these
approaches that we can treat attribute
and relationship data differently right
because we have we consider them as
different data types so we can treat
them differently it's though we don't
need to use radios as I told you mean we
are using the radios as the objective
function only in order to analyze the
theoretical properties of the algorithm
and to design an approximation algorithm
right in practice you would always use
the k-means version of the problem ok
then let me move on to the application
we don't want to miss your big market
segmentation had been our driving a
application and but I mean as you all
know market data or customer data is
very sensitive and hard to obtain so
instead we performed some experiments
using some DBP data for community
identification and if you will market
segmentation can be understood as a
special case of community identification
so we use the tiny data set with 50
orders described by the research
interest attribute data and the
co-author relationships to class labels
were manually determined for the orders
and this is also the reason why we use
this tiny data set only because we had
to manually
label the orders as belonging to one of
the computing science research
communities this figure presents our
experimental results comparing the case
enter algorithm against the Nets gain
algorithm and you observe that the next
can algorithm can significantly improve
the accuracy from 54 to seventy two
percent all these occurs is of course
relatively low but don't forget that we
are dealing with an unsupervised
clustering problem rather than a
supervised classification problem now we
also perform some more significant
experiments using a larger data set
again based on the dblp data set so we
expected 1555 papers with that term
frequencies and co all that
relationships so we connected two papers
if they share at least one order we use
conferences as surrogate class labels so
in this case we could automatically
label author object documents assuming
that the conference's serve as so good
for the communities and our experimental
results again quite encouraging and in
this case we were actually using the
k-means version of net scan as opposed
to the k center version so we compared
nets candy commands conine's version of
net skin again in connecticut came in
the garden and we could improve the
classification I sorry clustering
accuracy quite dramatically from
sixty-two percent to seventy-seven
percent now why perform join cluster
analysis well on such a community
identification task let's be if you take
a look at this portion of our DBP data
set the nodes represent papers edges
representing co-authored relationships
located
the point represent the term frequency
values now the line here in the middle
separate the clusters discovered by lk
means based on anti-mood values only now
let's zoom in into two interesting
papers here this paper by faking it are
on ferry strategies for price
information this based on the attribute
values on the keyword occurring in the
title and in the abstract this paper
would be assigned to the database Custer
and this is what k means ends up now if
you look at the relationship data this
paper is linked only two orders and
papers from the theory community and
this allows us allows next can to grant
me a sign this paper to the theory
community so this is so the label nets
can label it as a theory paper there's
also the opposite case when we look at
this paper by camping at our gossip
based a computation of aggregate
information this paper is more closely
linked to or more densely linked to
database papers and database orders it's
linked to for database papers and only
22 theory papers here by taking into
account the attribute information term
frequencies nets can can correctly
assign it to the theory community okay
so these are basic out regionally
driving applications market segmentation
community identification document
classroom now let's consider some
different quite different applications
for joint class analysis such as gene
clustering gene trusting is an extremely
important task in more
biology with the goal of finding
clusters of genes with similar function
now so far only gene expression data has
been used for this time with very few
exceptions and there have been hundreds
if not thousands of papers published on
clustering gene expansion data however
turns out that there is lots of
relationship being available than code
and should be included in the task of
clustering a generator consider for
example protein protein in turn X
interaction networks considering this
kind of interaction networks would allow
us to class the genes that interact and
have similar gene expression profiles
considering the upstream sequence data
the upstream sequence data that controls
the expression of the downstream gene
considering these upstream sequence data
we could cluster genes that share some
transcription factor binding sites and
and transcription factors are brought
into the doc upstream of a gene and
control the expansion of the gene so we
could find genes that share some
transcription factors and have similar
gene expression profile similar
attribute values last but not least we
could also make use of the wealth of
published results of scientific papers
so we could for example cluster genes
that are mentioned in the same article
or in the same articles which gives us
some relationship data and have similar
expression profiles and we have already
some preliminary results on this
application which are very encouraging
now another application is a clustering
crime data for the sake of hotspot
analysis and criminologists they are
interested in finding clusters of crimes
which they call hot sports in such an
application attributes would represent
the numbers of crimes in a certain spot
or in a certain small area
within a certain period of time
relationships would represent the rich
ability by a certain networks for
example the road on public
transportation network so how could join
cast analysis be applied in such a
context you know let's consider this
point example here where we have sub
urban downtown and in industrial area
separated by this river in the middle
now don't cluster analysis and could
find us these two connected areas of
high crime spots note that this area
here in downtown is connected via this
bridge across the river the surrounding
areas would be partitioned into
connected components of lower crime
rates so we would end up with 11 low
code spot area code spotty another codes
but he another quote but here these guys
are not connected and interestingly and
importantly this area of high crime and
sports would not be considered as a
cluster because there's no connection
between these guys and this is what
criminologists for example would want to
accomplish in such a situation so last
but not least I want to mention a
somewhat more speculative application
for image segmentation so image
segmentation we want to find clusters of
pixels with so-called segments which
hopefully correspond to some logical
real-world objects and pixels would be
described by a color values such as RGB
values as well as the relationships
representing the neighborhood's spatial
proximity zor neighborhoods of pixels
now this line actually shows some parent
image results off of the student project
from my class in the last fall term on
the left-hand side we have the original
images in the middle we have the net
scan results on the right-hand side we
have the k-means result of a classical
image segmentation algorithm and it
turns out that the CKC problem is quite
the appropriate to model the situation
the results of the net gain algorithm
are pretty competitive if not a
significantly better in pataca in cases
of very difficult to segment images okay
let me come to my conclusion we have
introduced the concept of John cluster
analysis considering attribute data as
well as relationship data we have in
fact occur introduced one possible a
problem definition in this paradigm the
connected case in the problem we have
performed in complexity analysis we have
presented a three approximation
algorithm we have also proposed an
efficient algorithm the net gain
algorithm that scales well to large data
sets we have performed some experimental
evaluation that shows that the net scan
results a more effort and as we argue
more natural than the results of
existing clustering algorithms there are
lots of applications such as community
identification market segmentation gene
clustering crime hotspot analysis these
applications also propose some
interesting direction for future work
there was already a question raised from
the audience what if not all edges are
available this is I guess
practical concern in community
identification as well as for example in
molecular biology normally not all of
the protein-protein interaction for
example could be assumed to be known in
advance so there's certainly some future
work that is suggested by some of these
applications that we have discussed I
mean there's actually a little different
connectivity constraints seem to be
meaningful in different applications and
here on this slide I'm listing stricter
connectivity constraints with theirs
both are cases that do make sense
malfini there are certain applications
where this connectivity constrained that
so that cluster needs we simply
connected is not strict enough in
certain applications you want to find
densely connected clusters and specify
for example by a certain minimum average
degree or as specified by a certain
maximum graph diameter of the cluster as
we have seen already mean there are also
cases where less spec connectivity
concern seems to be appropriate
accommodating missing data unknown
information in the grafts fracture
another interesting direction is
clustering without a priori knowledge of
the number of clusters this is a common
criticism of the partitioning and
clustering algorithm that in certain in
many cases actually the user finds it
very difficult to specify this number K
of classes in advance now and we are
currently working on on the problem
definition of joint class analysis that
does not assume up your knowledge of the
number K of classes you the challenges
to balance the casting accuracy the
radius and the model complexity right we
want to avoid the trivial solution of
assigning each point to a singleton
custom so we need to penalize complex
models the last topic that I want to
mention here in my outlook on future
work is overlapping clusters a noise
like in the classical partitioning
clustering
algorithm paradigms the Casey Casey
problem uniquely assigns every node to
exactly one cluster now there are both
other cases it's quite common that
natural clusters may indeed overlap in
communities for example or in document
collection it makes a lot of sense to
assign certain objects to multiple
classes on the other hand they may be
pointed cannot be assigned to any of the
clusters in a meaningful way which
should be considered as noise object now
so this is these are requirements that
should be considered which are however
non-trivial mean even for the classical
case of k-means or k center of example
there are few very convincing solution
the challenge is that if we allow
overlap and noise we need to somehow
restrict overlapping noise again in
order to avoid trivial solution so we
are currently working on some a problem
definition that defines an objective
function it tries to define a balance
between these two conflicting goals so
these are my references thank you very
much for your attention and I guess we
have time for a handful of more
questions
knocking against Scott on the edge so at
least relationship right so right now do
you have any numerical value on the
relationship stronger back put nope but
you you do have a way of measuring the
violation of constraint on inside just a
few st now ya mean no mean so far we
don't need the heuristic for the
violation of constraints our constraint
in the CKC problem is very simple that's
boolean constraints are either said
connected or not connected right and
this is strictly enforced we we could
make yes mean if you if I mean if you
take this document clustering
application we could use for example the
number of shared crew orders for example
as a numerical wait right right or if we
have for example in the community in a
community identification application if
we know for example how many emails
these guys having changed over a certain
period of time we could use this to wait
definitely right but then we need to
modify the connectivity constraint right
then certainly the current a solution
that just find connected the components
would not be appropriate anymore right
then we need to have a certain for
example we could use this version or
where we have a certain graph diameter
right so we could request that the crust
that cluster elements are reachable
within a certain graph distance so that
the shortest path between across the
center and any cluster member does not
exceed a certain length
come today average stress yes had kind
of alluded to it in your gene expression
example we can have multiple types of
relationships so for example you want to
use good the ups upstream of combining a
relationship and protein-protein
interaction oh I was not suggesting that
that could be interesting thing i would
suggest i was considering them as as
alternatives in its but mean this is
certainly now if we have multiple types
of relationships yeah yeah okay I mean
this is a question that we have not yet
discussed them
yeah I guess I mean that that could make
sense but I guess this would be a major
extension of the framework mean Connor
can take a one trivial one but I don't
know yes you do you could keep track of
multiple graphs and which all new
exposures to pay yes I insist on being
connected in each of the graphs yes but
I don't know what is actually going to
be useful because it's an injunction
maybe tues yeah you could also you could
also require that nodes are connected in
any and at least one of the grass right
this would be a simple extension how
meaningful it is but they have a single
wait they would have vectors of ways
responding yes if you can figure out the
relationship think of it as a cascade of
graphs like ruined makes box thing right
you know you are linked you are ready to
somebody else and they played this game
so as a second-order jump you could be
pretty much good to us so something like
that if you have multiple relations
which can cascade that can also form
some kind of a good yes Missy yeah I
mean as long as you reduce the multiple
graphs somehow into one graph right then
we are back to this family of problem
definitions so and I'm certainly not
saying that this is not a meaningful
direction what I'm saying is I would say
for the next little while we would
probably want to restrict ourselves to
further investigate this problem of
seeing assuming a single attribute
vector and the single graph structure
underlying our graph these I think these
extensions to take into account missing
they
rated edges and so forth I think are
easier to attack then using a multiple
graphs because we have some intuition of
what we would expect from the problem
definition and the solution
thank you